deux chats est l'incarnation du mal et
du bien
au japon par exemple chape est considéré
comme un animal dangereux parce qu'il a
le pouvoir de s'incarner de le tuer les
femmes et dans le bouddhisme que vous
dites me reproche beaucoup aux chats le
fait qu'avec le serpent est le seul
animal à ne pas s'être ému de la mort de
bouddha
les gens quand ils étaient petits un
jour tu ouvres aimait beaucoup les
animaux ce fut mon sujet ce tir éditeurs
nous avons tous les animaux et continue
gaillard oui est ce qui fait avec nab à
vitry du prises sont chassés nabab c'est
la mab il a volé à corinne parce qu'elle
aurait signé d'accord et on la met aux
fers à corinne corinne remake ici
lorsque nous nous sommes rencontrés avec
tabac bat la campagne
karim est d'obtenir cet automne un tout
petit chat et tout de suite nous avons
sympathisé
nous avons fait une connaissance plus
approfondie nous sommes dans communiqué
tous les deux pendant quelques jours et
j'ai décidé et lui avec quelques pas que
il viendrait vivre avec moi et un jour
est parti en italie pour tourner un film
elle me l'a confié il s'est avéré que ce
chat c'est absolument à nos ados régent
et qui la pelure et corinne le poulain
ne vous en a pas voulu
il manquerait plus que ça
madame le poulain 85 ans un fils célèbre
jean le poulain vedettes internationales
deux petites filles aussi jolie
excellente comédienne corinne le poulain
dont la réputation n'est plus à faire et
la benjamine vanik 20 ans
le plan les poulains c'est aussi le plan
des amis des animaux
car high tech la gouttière qui
couvriront les jardins du luxembourg du
tout avoir une dizaine de jours à peu
près on me l'a portée dans une boîte de
souliers vous savez en carton ils
étaient misérables misérable misérable
on l'a soignée et c'est devenu le vos
chats vous voyez on l'aurait choisi les
extrêmes l'antagonisme n'aurait pas pu
trouver mieux
le karak et un est un chat de gouttière
rend pas peur du mot il m'écoute pas non
ça va pas d'évêque son armement un pack
anthony qu'ils ont chaque goutte hier le
shaq a été trouvé il devrait bondir la
rue est un enfant de la balle et qui va
vivre la maison louis 15 heures marquées
alors ça c'est un shaq est excessivement
sauvage et y ait une grande d'une grande
hauteur
c'est une grande distinction de penser
une grande hystérie sur le coeur ils
s'abandonnent à personne ni à ma mère
qui existe pas et il y à une retenue
notamment alors avec moi tout à fait
très grande une marque les distances
total qui peut y avoir entre maman
corinne et moi ça bat andy gradient et
ben moi je suis tu l'as fait au bas de
l'échelle
tandis que nabab au contraire qui
devrait être normalement un seigneur de
part son plumage n'est pas éteint
lumières sont tout à fait amicale
familier d'abord très facile n'est pas
tous mes amis là bas bien leur faire les
bons jours d' usage alors que kara ne
paraissent jamais dit bonjour à personne
passe et 1 c'est un seigneur très
distant ils ont les mêmes goûts pour le
repas sains non pas du tout pas du tout
il y en a un qui embellissent abdine
l'autre les aiment pas et rognons pétrir
mais même dans la nourriture vous savez
dans la nourriture nacarat je vous le
dis maman la fin du but le dire parce
que naturellement car est parée de
toutes les vertus et de toutes les
qualités mais il a des gros problèmes
pour la nourriture ils ne mangent pas
n'importe quoi il ya des choses qui sont
les boîtes concerne sutton le même pas
question mêmes sont nos est pas si son
nom l'autre chat ou un chien de passage
errant sur allemand est venu boire ou
simplement s'approcher de son âge c'est
terminé ils ne voient pas ils ne mangent
pas alors il tape avec le pied comme ça
devant la loge du regard de ma banque
qui résistent eu parce qu'il ya eu une
conversation
quelquefois il bosse
le bol d'eau il renverse aussi peu pour
bien montrer sa désapprobation
alors on sait qu'il faut le changer le
voit ce moment là
c'est un chantier très qui est très beau
que très noble qui est très mystérieux
passé avec l'habit singe pas que
l'animal de pubis terje il ya quelque
chose de de très lointain il a toujours
d'un des yeux absolument admirable
étonnant et j'avoue que lorsque je le
regarde comme ça un petit peu repos
c'est un espèce de support de méditation
que les yeux de mon chat
au cambodge où j'ai vécu très longtemps
eh bien on promenait dans certaines
cérémonies rituelles ont promené un chat
enfermé dans une cage n'est pas pour
d'aborder la plus il est le chat et
s'écrit suppliant permettait à hydra de
faire tomber la pluie
vous avez vu ça à faire tomber la pluie
a conduit chat oui non j'avoue que j'ai
pas encore participé